regardez cet art et revient d'être
déboucher le sang circule de nouveau un
patient va survivre à cette à baisser et
cela grâce à une toute nouvelle
technique unique aux antilles la
thrombectomie mécanique
mais avant d'en arriver là pour avoir la
vie sauve
le patient aura suivi un circuit de
soins extrêmement précis et commence ici
au centre d'appel du 15 grâce à des
questions précises ces professionnels
sont en mesure de suspecter des abc
l'avc est une urgence il faut que le
patient arrive tu invites à l'hôpital
sans intermédiaire les pompiers sont
immédiatement
vient ensuite une prise en charge très
spécifique aux urgences de l'hôpital
les pompiers nous annonce une suspicion
d'accident vasculaire cérébral ont fait
un examen médical pour confirmer cette
suspicion d'avc et en même temps on
appelle le neurologue le neurologue
c'est en quelque sorte le chef
d'orchestre de la prise en charge
c'est lui qui confirme le diagnostic
d'abaisser en partie avec l'irm et c'est
lui aussi qui détermine le type de soins
offrir à chaque patient il faut que le
patient qu'on puisse voir des patients
dans les six premières heures et le plus
rapidement possible parce que plus on
fait un geste de reconnaissance ion tôt
et plus pronostic est meilleur
aussi bien sur le plan est vital que sur
le plan aussi du pronostic fonctionnel
de la fonction du handicap
une fois ces étapes capitales franchi
les patients ayant les abaisser les plus
graves pourront bénéficier de la fameuse
thrombectomie mécanique
ce 30 hôpitaux la pratique en france
inutile de dire qu'en martinique c'est
une vraie révolution c'est une
révolution qu'on attendait depuis une
trentaine d'années qui permet de
déboucher les artères du cerveau dans
certaines indications
dans les avc ce n'est pas dans tous les
avc mais enfin c'est pour ceux que cela
concerne c'est une révolution avec des
résultats excellents puisque on débouche
les artères dans 80% des cas
mais voilà il n'ya qu'un neuroradiologue
hautement qualifiés qui peut pratiquer
la thrombectomie mécanique
aujourd'hui le professeur medjoubi est
donc le seul à pouvoir soigner les
patients de martinique et ceux de la
guadeloupe qui arrive en hélicoptère et
en urgence mais face aux résultats
spectaculaires de la thrombectomie
mécanique la société française de
neuroradiologie fait venir des
spécialistes sur notre île pour
renforcer les équipes
c'est le cas de ce médecin on a déjà une
quinzaine de praticiens hospitaliers de
mes deux métropoles qui sont
neuroradiologie interventionnelle comme
moi et qui ont donné leur accord de
principe pour venir passer une durée de
deux à trois semaines et il faut
maintenant qu'on
motive qu'on transforme l'essai et qu'on
organise la succession de ces séjours
pour pouvoir organiser ici ce qu'on
appelle une permanence des soins
c'est ça qui d'un bruit s'il s'agit pas
d'avoir de temps en temps un praticien
qui vient suppléer le professeur mais
j'oublie qui est tout seul à faire ça en
martinique est vraiment il faut lui
rendre hommage parce qu'il a mis en
place cette thérapeutique cette
alternative thérapeutique la trame et
tommy ne peut pas être sur la brèche
toutes les nuits tous les week-ends il y
a urgence à former des neuroradiologue
en martinique
cette technique sauve des vies mais elle
permet aussi de limiter très
sérieusement le risque de handicap un
véritable espoir pour les 1200
guadeloupéen et martiniquais qui sont
frappées chaque année par un avc
ischémique